now the international monetary fund has
released its latest economic forecast
for the world focusing on inflation and
growth both struggling to recover
post-pandemic the report says that the
global economy is still faces
significant challenges in the year ahead
Patty culhane has more from Washington
D.C
you don't usually see people in a food
bank look quite as excited as Nancy
canos
my birthday cake
but he made one nobody gave me one now
this is not your typical food bank Mana
Food Center in Maryland doesn't just
give those in need a box of pre-selected
food but they get to shop for the
essentials they actually like
they are now serving the highest number
of people in its 40-year history having
opportunities like this allow me to
use my money in other ways without
worrying about having to worry about the
struggle of getting food food prices
have soared by almost six percent in the
US this year impacting people across the
socioeconomic Spectrum for many of them
they say this is my first time ever
coming to a food bank I've never asked
for help before but right now I just
can't afford the prices in the grocery
store and the price of gas and
everything else so a lot of a lot of
first-time families that we see every
week the international monetary fund
forecasts inflation in the U.S and in
most countries around the globe will get
better but not by much this year
about 98 of the countries that have
inflation targets
uh have inflation above the Target and
going into next year into 2024 that
number you know is going from from 98 to
89 which means more people will need to
come here not just in the coming months
but likely years ahead I can't even
drive places do you understand gas is
just so high right now so the things
that I've used to have done before I
just can't do anything everything is
just pretty much limited for Millions
across the globe this isn't just about a
forecast or even the numbers but a
constant state of sacrifice that the
international monetary fund says will
continue for some time Patty gold hey Al
Jazeera Washington Luis Vieira is
coordinator of the Bretton Woods project
a group of critical voices that acts as
a watchdog of both the IMF and the World
Bank he says that many challenges still
lie ahead for the global economy
the report shows that we continue to
face very difficult and challenging
times ahead and we would highlight that
these uh the Dynamics that are outlined
in the Outlook we really would stress
that these some of these Dynamics
predate the covet crisis right I think
many people tend to look at these
difficulties as stemming principally
from the covid pandemic and the war on
Ukraine whereas we would argue that
Global growth and Dynamics were quite
challenging even prior to the pandemic
and you can see for example the
Secretary General of the United Nations
the World Bank uh have highlighted that
we're indeed in a crisis of development
right and we were talking about the
reform of the international architecture
the World Bank has undertaken their own
reform there's there's quite a concern
obviously around the inability to
respond to the climate emergency so you
know the growth masks many other
Dynamics we are really living in
throughout also a crisis of
multilateralism there's quite uh you
know fading trust in the multilateral
system in states you have the rise of
far-right uh States so you know the the
fact that this this report notes
actually that growth yes is increasing a
bit but it's still from a very low
Benchmark comparatively speaking